to sum up we've had an amazing ride here
at Tesla and I'm so excited to lead this
company into the future with that I'll
take any questions from the audience yes
mr. Bob I have a very tiny shareholder
with only two shares but as all the
other investors in this room I may be
interested in one thing you guys have
not made a single penny yes when it is
when is this company comfortable you all
know what this feels like don't you and
this is not where you want to be today
will provide you with one of your last
lessons at the GSB a lesson on how to
answer tough business questions there
are three types of tough business
questions the first are those questions
for which you do not have an answer the
second are those questions for which you
cannot provide an answer and the third
are those questions for which you are
guilty as charged
we will provide you with an example of
each one of these questions and then
offer some suggestions on how to best
address each of those questions but
first I would like to offer credit to
Jerry Weissman's book in the line of
fire from which we synthesize many of
these suggestions so what does it look
like when you don't know the answer to a
question when is your Hawaii office
opening I'm looking for a job are you
kidding me
I'm the CEO of Tesla for crying out loud
I have better things to worry about
maybe August or December stop there is a
much better way to address a question
for which you do not have an answer
first begin by rephrasing or restating
the question
as you best understood it this will do
two things it'll ensure that the
audience member feels heard but it will
also confirm for you the question for
which you must ultimately provide an
answer second no audience member expects
you to be a walking encyclopedia so if
you don't know the answer admit it
you really have nothing to gain and have
everything to lose by lying if you lie
you provide inaccurate information and
you risk damaging your reputation
finally best practice is actually commit
to falling up and do follow up you can
even demonstrate this intent by asking
for that audience members business card
or contact information so let's try that
again when do you open your Hawaii
office I'm looking for a job so you want
to know when you might be able to apply
for a job in Hawaii to be honest I don't
know exactly when our Hawaii office will
be opening however I do know that we are
rapidly expanding all across the globe
and are looking for talented individuals
in many locations I do actually have my
head of HR Leslie here with me she'd be
happy to meet with you after this
presentation
she'd know when the Hawaii office will
be opening and she'd be happy to answer
any other questions that you might have
now what do you do if you receive a
question to which you cannot answer
maybe because of confidentiality reasons
let's try this mr. musk can you comment
on your negotiations with local state
authorities in jurisdictions where
tessai cannot currently open any stores
have you made any political
contributions in those states maybe of
course we'd be silly not to we have a
good friend an old fraternity brother of
the CFO Jerry Arlen he's in Texas and
conveniently he sits on the Texas
Transportation Board
needless to say we think we have pretty
strong negotiating leverage with the
auto dealers there we're currently
negotiations to get full access to sell
in the state of Texas and it should be
done in a couple weeks
Wow I'm sure Jerry Arlen will allow to
see this back on television tonight
first if your company policy states that
you cannot share any information just
say so everyone knows that certain
information cannot be shared and no one
will be surprised with that however try
to do so in a positive way rather than
saying our company does not share this
kind of information try to say our
company policy only allows to share
information that has been previously
released in press releases second if you
can't share certain information give a
reason for why you can't share that
information you can attribute this to
privacy or security or data sensitivity
for example third if you have any extra
relevant information to share do so with
your audience and last but not least
never ever answer this question by
saying if I tell you I'll have to kill
you so let's write it again mr. musk can
you comment on your negotiations with
local state authorities and in
jurisdictions where Tesla cannot open
any store currently did you make any
political contributions in those states
maybe so we want customers to be able to
buy a Tesla wherever they live and as
you allude to unfortunately that's not
today's reality however we are
negotiations with several state
authorities across the United States and
we're working hard to bring Tesla
customers those cars however to keep
open and honest negotiations it's our
policy not to comment on ongoing
discussions but I can assure you that
we're working tirelessly to allow every
customer to be able to buy a Tesla where
they live
that was waiter you're doing well but
you're not off the hook yet I still have
one more question for you
and one more advice for you what should
you do if the questionnaire has a valid
point what if we ask something that
points out one of your weaknesses so
let's try this
mr. mask how do you expect anyone to buy
a card from you if they are expected to
spend 75 minutes on a charging station
did you get this information from the
University of Phoenix who let this bozo
in here
no our customers have shown no reticence
to buy cars if they take a long time to
charge we have no problems with this at
all how would you feel if you were the
questioner how would you feel if a valid
concern is dismissed
in this way I will explain you a better
way of answering a different way of
answering first but a phrase the
questioner and reframe the question in a
way that you show that you listen and
you change the tone of the question to
make it more possible to make the most
propose it then agree with a questioner
he has a valid point show him that
you're on his side you're not an
opponent and then say loud and clear but
and make a u-turn to change the tone of
the answer in a positive way so you can
present evidence to defend your own
position while still acknowledging the
existence of this issue and finally you
have to conclude with a strong statement
so again mr. masks I will have your
second chance
how do you expect people to buy a doubt
if they are expected to spend 75 minutes
on a charging station what I'm hearing
from you is that you have a concern that
people might not want to purchase a
Tesla if it takes a long time to
recharge I think that's a valid concern
and it's something that I spend a lot of
time thinking about currently it takes
about 40 minutes for us to give the car
an 80 percent charge and the 75 minutes
you mentioned is for a full charge but
we've been working really hard and have
taken several important steps to try to
mitigate this issue firstly we just
introduced battery swaps where people
can come into a station switch in a new
battery in 90 seconds that's faster than
filling up a tank of gas and secondly
we're constantly working to improve our
battery technology and as we can charge
the car faster we're going to get people
out on the road faster and more and more
people will want to buy our amazing
vehicles that was the answer I wanted to
hear the first congratulations so let's
recap what we learned today we learn how
to answer three questions when you don't
know the answer say so and offer
follow-up when you can't answer just
don't but always provide a reasonable
explanation for not answering and when
the questioner has a valid point admit
guilt it's fine it's good to connect
with them but you have to spend enough
time to defend your position and to
explain why the concern has been
addressed we have seen him how he
evolved throughout the presentation he
has successfully answered three
questions and he's ready to take the
fourth one from you